are we ready for the
serpent why the
serpent are we ready for the
serpent why the bronze
serpent come on now we need to refocus
regroup
reather so now why did the Lord God
fashion the image of a bronze serpent on
a pole you guys ready I already answered
this in the previous session but I'll
answer it again on a poll do you know
why
that represented the serpent being
impaled and
killed the serpent on a pole represents
the serpent
being killed impaled right on the pole
that the serpent was put to death why
because what caused Israelites to Die
the venomous poisonous bite of the fiery
serpents so that
symbolize the
death the
impalement of the cause of their death
that which caused them to die was put to
death that which caused them to die was
put to death okay everyone
there yep Genesis 3:15 I'm G to get
there Andy I'm G to get to Genesis 315
thank you brother I want to connect it
now what's amazing if you go to numbers
214 to9 you'll see that the words in
Hebrew for the serpent they're
called h
Sim the word Sim is the same word in
Isaiah 6 ver2 seraphim what was standing
Before the Throne of God sarim
seraphim what were sarim these Spirit
creatures with six wings two they hid
their face two they flapped and two they
covered their feet that's the same word
in Isaiah 62 used in numbers 21 sarim
H sarim sarim okay I want you to make
the connection not only were those
serpents that b isites called sarim
sarim they're
called you know what the word nashim is
it's the plural
of that's the Hebrew word for serpent
that's the Hebrew word used for the
serpent in the garden
the word for the serpent in the garden
is
Nash so what did God say make an image
of the fiery
serpent being impaled because that
symbolizes the destruction of Satan who
brought death into the World by causing
the first parents to sin
you with me
there okay now I want you to go here
click on the Interlinear Interlinear
here it is can you click and confirm
that the word for fiery serpent is SAR
sarif can you click and see SAR sarif
singular of sarim the very Spirit
creatures that fly Before the Throne of
God can you confirm that before I move
on
okay confirm it let me see another
thing hold on and here's what I want you
to do when you do that here's verse n
you
confirmed it's set off now here is verse
n can you click there and
confirm that the word there for serpent
is Nash set Nash fiery serpent
serpent can you guys click on and
confirm what John oliviera the
connection is that when you tie these
pieces together you can make a strong
case Satan was a sarap he was one of the
seraphim because the seraphim are
Serpentine they look like serpents even
though they're not and they can change
their shape and form and the seraphim of
Isaiah 6 are identified as the four
living creatures in Revelation CH 4 and
5 Revelation chapter 4 and 5 when you
read the description of the four living
creatures they look like the seraphim of
Isaiah 6 but also like the cherubim of
Ezekiel 10 so if you read Ezekiel 10
look what look at the description of the
cherubim what they look like they're
identical to the four living creatures
of Revelation 4 and5 Before the Throne
but also the four living creatures are
described like the seraphim of Isaiah 6
what does that mean when we tie it in
Satan must have been a sarif a
cherub who was Serpentine in his
appearance but could change shape and
form who then rebelled against God which
would then explain why when he caused
Adam and Eve to sin cherubim were sent
to guard the way of the entrance into
the Garden of Eden to take of the Tree
of Life why cherubim because Satan was
one of them who now rebelled so one of
his own are now guarding the way to the
tree of
life and I did a session on this if you
go back on my YouTube channel type in
Satan I did some sessions on this where
I go really in depth so everyone got it
thus far so why a bronze serpent because
that's the picture that God is putting
to death the cause of their death what
caus is us to die the venomous bite of
the fiery serpents so what did God to
then heal them of their death heal them
of that poison taking the cause of their
death and nailing
it putting the cause of their
death to
death you got it
now is it making
sense you got it now how does This Ti
with Jesus what did Jesus
do what did he do he took your sins that
cause you to die in his body and nailed
the cause of your death to the Cross
burying it with
him you catch
it michah Grace I'll get back to
that because what causes you to die sin
so what did Jesus do took your sins in
his body and then nailed it to the tree
burying it first Peter 2:24 1 Peter
2:24 but then I'm going to tie in with
Genesis
3:15 well Catholic was a term meaning
Universal so everyone who's a member of
the church was part of The Universal
Church the catholicos Ecclesia The
Universal Church the Catholic church now
1 Peter
2:24 who his own self bear our sins in
his own body on the tree that we being
dead to
sins should live unto righteousness by
whose Stripes you were healed now let me
make another connection with Jesus's
cross Genesis 315 with Jesus's cross now
sarand you heard it yesterday but I'm
going repeat it again
yes yes we're all Catholics and that we
are the members of the spiritual body of
Jesus Christ which is universal Catholic
located all over the Earth why do you
think this s Church of the East calls
itself the
holy Apostolic Catholic Church of the
East it's called The Holy Apostolic
Catholic Church of the East and even
Orthodox use the term Catholic now read
Genesis 3:15 guys read this and I will
put enmity between thee he's talking to
the serpent and the woman and between
thy seed and her seed her seed will
bruise your head and you shall bruise
his heel now when you have a poisonous
serpent biting your heel you die
right even Isaiah
14:29 Jesus is our Passover Isaiah 14:29
so when a serpent bites your heel you
die right but I want you to catch the
imagery let's see if you caught it
for the serpent to bite your heel that
means it's by your leg right your foot
that means the serpent is put in a
position now even though it bites you
you canot crush its head so the serpent
in biting his heel allows the seed to
now use his heel to crush his head ah
you bit me right now I can crush your
head crush his head and kill him so you
see the genius and the wisdom of God the
Beauty and the wisdom and the of God's
knowledge and mind and how deep the
Bible is when you bite his heel you are
now close enough to be by his feet and
that will now allow the seed to then
Crush you under his feet under his
heel so when did that happen Matthew
2733 when did that happen Matthew 273
let's see who's going to catch
it I mentioned this a while back we're
going to mention it again Matthew 27:33
let's see who's going to catch it you
got it
Arthur Protestant you there bro and when
they were come unto a place called gotha
that is to say a place of a skull did
you catch it the mound looked like a
head a skull Jesus on the cross beam
that Cross Beam would have to be planted
into the ground to remain fixed a
perfect picture of the seed of the woman
who's being bitten by the serpent as he
now crushes the head of the serpent by
his spiritual spear the
cross man what's going on
here any doubt your Holy Bible is the
perfect preserved word of God
and the god of the Bible is real he's
alive he's Almighty and that because
Jesus is Alive we don't need to fear
death if he terries when we die he will
then give us the grace and fill us with
the spirit to go through death and see
him because he's
alive aren't you Blown Away How deep the
Bible is How Majestic the Bible is and
the meat of scripture if you ask Holy
Spirit to illuminate you you cannot help
but fall in love with this word and the
God of this word